today we're check us out starting out
great this is the echo spot it's
essentially a squish down circular
version of the echo show I unbox the
echo show here not too long ago Alexa
oh it's updating what do I do this has
taken a really long time and since then
I have got the echo show for pretty much
everyone I know as gifts because it is
probably one of my favorite devices in a
very very long time for Christmas I got
my dad one of these and the echo show
and what's great about this is it has a
screen it's integrated with Alexa and
it's kind of just like this little tiny
mini computer that just sits around your
house but it also has a built in camera
so you could make Alexa I keep calling
them Alexa time calls I think it feels
like Alexa time I don't think that's
good it's cold it's essentially a
FaceTime but calling through Alexa when
I saw they announced the spot i
pre-ordered this immediately these came
out the end of December so let's just
stop talking and open it oh yeah this
looks great they have two different
versions they have a black and a white
they also have the echo show in a black
and a white version too I chose the
black version mostly because the one
that I got originally was black so I
thought let's just match that looks like
a magic 8-ball that's been cut in half
well Justine shattered her iPhone within
the next month don't shake it that's a
good hold you go like this no are you
sure cuz you're shaking it there's
bubbles and then there's apparently it
is decidedly so that I'm going to
shatter my phone in the next month the
setup on these are pretty simple
you basically just plug it in you
connect it to your Wi-Fi and you
connected to your Alexa app on your
phone so here it is I mean it really
does just looks like it's chopped in
half magic 8-ball plugged in hello my
ghost pod is ready for set up so it's
kind of cool because this is a touch
screen so you can interact with this
directly just have to type in my Wi-Fi
password since this is already connected
to my network and I already have one set
up it already says welcome Justine and
if that's you you type yes yes that's me
checking for latest software
days this is where things tend to take a
hot minute what I really like about this
too is you can enable drop in so if you
want to drop in on any of your friends
who have also enabled drop in and
allowed you to drop in on them you
basically could just say her name
call so-and-so and then it'll allow you
to view their camera which yes I know
that sounds completely absolutely
terrifying but that is an option that
you can turn off so it's not like this
is something that just it because you
have this you can do that it is an
option you could turn it off don't worry
echo spot device will update it okay
install that as I install the updates
your echo spot will restart twice okay
good to know so if one of your friends
has the Alexa app and they don't
necessarily have one of these they can
still talk to you and contact you they
just have to have the app I'm so sorry
if any of you guys have your on she's
probably going crazy right now because I
keep saying the name and I'm so so sorry
from here on out if I'm not talking to
her I'm gonna call her I feel like this
is an episode of Gossip Girl one of the
big trends at CES this year was
integrating everything with a and Google
so if you have a Google assistant where
you have a or even Vic speed if you're a
Samsung user integrating all of these
little smart home devices into other
things so for example at the LG booth I
was using the remote control to navigate
my lights in my house but that was using
Google assistant so because it was
hooked up to Louisville assistant I
didn't actually have to say hey Google
trying to space it out because if you
guys have these devices I know they're
going crazy this thing is still updating
so I'm still talking to you guys another
thing that you can do with this is you
can use green room calling so I have one
of these in the kitchen so as soon as
this thing is set up I can use this to
call down to the kitchen if I'm
traveling and I have my a app open and I
have drop in and abled I can drop in
from anywhere in the world to my home
and see what's going on kind of sounds a
little terrifying does it it is but then
it isn't I mean this is the future so
you either get with it or you don't or
night soon yep spot is ready okay I
can't tell time on an analog clock
I need digital we've got the weather
what's five times 235 five x 235 is 1175
I love math Ed's home recently active so
we're gonna call my friend Edie hello
hello do you well you won't see me
because I'm filming you there you are
hello there I am
see how did the Internet hi Internet
what's going on so there's me later
wait where's a little oh there I am so
that's them right there what school did
you get the white wanted a black one I
got the black one to match the other
black one is cuz they have like are you
comes guys he always you always comes up
when someone's on you well this is me
robbing us with paid off it's really
cute
this thing is so great I love it oh my
goodness that's like the most precious
thing ever
well thanks for accepting my call yeah
okay well I'm gonna continue my review
my review is it so cold your that rig
yeah do you see that light I added my
new light up here no I said when I went
to CES I was doing a wily factor but I
started it too late it was at the end I
was like oh we should do a well we
factor from like 1 to like 100 and yeah
bye hi bye see how do I enter Alexa and
call Jack go into the app and I can do a
couple of the things in here and I can
make some little changes like I can
change the space so is it weird if I
make a photo on my Alexa a picture of me
holding the Alexa so I'm going to show
you really quick
that's an example no no so if I have
this in my office like I said before I
could just drop in using my phone and I
can see what's going on in my office
just using my phone so guys this is the
Alexis spot I'm such a huge fan of all
the things that amazon has been doing
with the integration of Alexa I'm so
excited for the future of what they're
gonna do because if this is what they
have now I can only imagine what they
already have in the works what can we
look forward to next I don't even know
but I can't wait to find out let me know
if you guys have any suggestions for
things that you'd like me to review or
unbox here and also let me know what you
think the future of Amazon is going to
make next I don't know
[Music]